buscan ayuda entre las estructuras
colapsadas quienes sobrevivieron al
terremoto esperan hallar entre las
ruinas alimentos para garantizar su
subsistencia
miles de haitianos esperan por ayuda
humanitaria los países de américa latina
fueron los primeros en solidarizarse
chile envió 16 toneladas en medicinas
kits de higiene comida y agua los
chilenos
sabemos y conocemos lo que significa un
terremoto devastador y lo que significa
en términos de sufrimiento y dolor para
las personas que tienen que vivir esas
adversidades y por eso tenemos todas las
razones del mundo para hoy día
acompañar solidarizar y ayudar al pueblo
haitiano en estos momentos de tanto
dolor y de tanta angustia méxico por su
parte envió toneladas de artículos de
primera necesidad a los insumos se suman
los equipos de búsqueda que apoyan las
tareas de rescate colombia envió 30
personas para ayudar en las labores
mientras que las autoridades haitianas
prometieron evitar los errores de 2010
cuando los recursos fueron dirigidos a
ongs que no brindaron la respuesta que
se esperaba nuble
queremos una mejor respuesta que la que
se dio al terremoto del 2010
el camino y toda la ayuda de afuera debe
ser coordinada con la agencia de
protección civil
la isla aún no se recuperaba de la
destrucción causada por el sismo del
2010 además enfrenta este desastre en
medio de un turbulento ambiente político
exacerbado por el asesinato de su
presidente job en el morir el 7 de julio